you're watching white coming up on this
week's show Angela's finding out how to
make money on social media I meet a
rising Instagram star trying to make us
all look beautiful and Gav's at the helm
of a Starfleet ship for this week's
games review welcome to the show
parents why we love a bit of social
media you'll already know that if you
follow us on Twitter so this week we
decided to hone in on social media
influences the people turning their
online followings into an income is
Angela I was making like about a
thousand between $1,000 and a thousand
pounds a day and then it stayed like
that for years and years and years and I
ended up making more than a million and
maybe 1.5 million or something and then
I bought a property in London and bought
a property and in Bangkok through his
love of traveling and sharing his
experiences online 32 year-old Johnny
Ward has managed to turn online clicks
into a lot of cash travel blogging is
now his full-time job thanks to building
a big audience and subsequently getting
paid by sponsors but there's some
controversy over the ethics of some
bloggers because of a lack of official
regulation we have arrived in Pyongyang
this British blogger was criticized for
his trip to North Korea appearing to
show it as a paradise
however he denied accusations that he
was being paid by the regime Instagram
and snapchat stars and lots of followers
are also getting paid vast amounts of
money to post about products and digital
agencies a big business now representing
and matching them up with appetizers so
what makes someone stand out and how do
they make sure they're posting
responsibly
you can't specialize in basic connecting
brands talent and audiences we work with
a lot of high profile kind of talent
mainly in the music and entertainment
space I would say when we're sort of
looking at who we're working with it's
really about talent with high reach in
some occasions but also really high
engagement our advice always to both
talent and brands is always to be very
transparent about any commercial
relationship the experts say to grow
your audience you should only share
useful or valuable content and only 20%
of it should be about you advice also
includes identifying trends and engaging
with followers and of course doing it
all responsibly the entire process
requires a lot of dedication a lot of
passion a bit of luck as well but it's
also very important which niche topic
you're focusing on right so and watch
what your target audiences as well so I
think if you if you try to match all
these ingredients there's a good chance
you're gonna succeed but you always need
to be prepared that's not going to be
the case with at least 2.3 billion
active social media you
around the world brands are adapting to
the changing way we can see in content
and products leaving the online world
wide open for anyone to make a profit
Angela bonds Sky News stay with us
still to come I'll be finding out what
the daily workload is like for a fashion
and beauty blogger that's coming right
up after a roundup of this week's tech
news NASA scientists have been putting
the finishing touches to a solar-powered
robotic spacecraft it's been designed to
get up close to the asteroid Bennu and
collect samples that could help
astronomers get information for
protecting Earth from future potential
asteroid collisions it's due to launch
next month a norwegian start-up has come
up with a way to keep children with
long-term illnesses connected to their
school friends and lessons while they're
at home recovering an avatar robot can
be controlled by the child from home
with cameras microphones and speakers so
they can even contribute to the class
but without actually being in the room
parents are due to spend three hundred
ninety seven pounds per household on
back-to-school gadgets for their
children this year almost tripled the
spend scene last year that's according
to a report by u s-- which research has
also found 95 percent of mums and dads
think tech will improve their child's
future career prospects the team behind
this YouTube channel which claims to
help your pooch fall asleep says it's
getting four million views per month
relax my dog develops music techniques
to help canines with anxiety problems
coming up we're on a mission in space
with the new Star Trek virtual reality
title but first so now we know how
social media influences are turning
clicks into cash but what's the typical
working day like keeping all those
followers interested I met Sophie Hannah
Richardson the fashion and beauty
blogger to find out hi Virata welcome
back to my channel as you can see I'm
covered in so much glitter and sequins
and I absolutely love it
Sophie Hannah Richardson has certainly
developed a unique brand her YouTube
channel describes her as the green
haired personal style blogger there
can't be many of those her videos
including hair and beauty tutorials have
been watched more than half a million
times but it's Instagram where she's got
her biggest audience with a hundred and
eighty thousand followers when we put
this week swipe together so no wonder
big-name Beauty companies are keen to
have her review their products so how do
you actually make money from what you're
doing
so brands will approach me by email
mostly and they will ask me to create
sponsored content whether that's a blog
post it might be a sponsored YouTube
video or an Instagram post and I kind of
charge a fee per content that money has
been good enough for Sophie to make this
her full-time career what a day's work
like one day could be shooting outfit
pictures the next I might be in London
I've got lots of meetings another day I
might be at a festival or a blogger
event in the evening so it's never ever
the same here are my five different
hairstyles are really easy and thick
trying out new looks might sound like
fun but there's a lot more to being a
blogger I don't think people realize the
amount of hard work that US bloggers do
a lot of the time we get comments and
they say oh you're just kind of just
wearing a dress but it's not that it's
the thought process that even goes into
styling an outfit then we have to edit
our pictures we edit our own videos
we've got to film the videos so it's a
lot of hours that goes into it
the bloggers ever get jealous of each
other unfortunately I think sometimes
they do it's a shame because there are
little cliques and I've heard stories
from other bloggers about some vloggers
kind of trying to steal their following
and things like that which I think's
petty because it's such a nice little
community and I've made amazing friends
from blogging and I think we can support
each other by sharing each other's
content do you have haters I do on
Instagram
it's hard when you when you get these
comments I have do now block the people
because most of time they're not even
following me anyway they just obviously
stumbled across my picture I just don't
understand when people feel the need to
comment negatively why is it you think
that people follow you my hair I think
next year my focus has kind of been
trying to be the blogger that everyone
comes to for something a bit different
that's kind of been my objective and
that's how she means to go on so if you
said she's excited to see where her next
step will take her now it's time for our
games review including a new release
from an independent developer here in
the UK
here's gap so last week I went to
cologne to Gamescom which is the biggest
game show in the world apparently and a
lot of people there and I saw a bunch of
new cool stuff some not so cool stuff as
well but I talked to you about the cool
stuff first of all I saw a little
nightmares and unfortunately the first
game I saw is probably the best game I
saw so kind of everything went downhill
for the rest of it but it's brilliant
it's like a little really creepy 2.5 D
platformer it's made by some of the guys
who did work on things like tearaway
unfolded and LittleBigPlanet and at
first glance you think it looks quite a
nice kind of game right those games but
it's actually really creepy and it's
meant to be based on children's
nightmares so every room kind of changes
like there was one room I was hanging
out at an abattoir doing this weird
sausage puzzle and then I swung on the
sausages through to a different room
that was filled with children shoes so
yeah it's a really creepy game and I
just really want to play more of it
another game that I played was called
the bunker which is made by Wales
Interactive and I'm Welsh so I was
obviously gonna like it but the game is
actually really good it's really strange
it's kind of like an FMV point-and-click
like mystery game apparently it's only
about two and a half hours long I played
an hour of it so I got pretty far into
the story but it's this really weird
mystery about a guy who's grown up in
this bunker his whole life and
apparently it's like a real sort of
underground bunker that these guys found
and they were able to film in but you're
not quite sure what's going on and
you're trying to solve these different
puzzles early on something really bad
happens to you and you're kind of
dealing with that but this is a guy
who's never been outside of his room so
you kind of have to deal with a lot of
mental stuff where he doesn't like doing
things that break his routine and
basically you're paid to break his
routine so you end up feeling pretty bad
about everybody who likes Star Trek is
probably dreamed about taking control of
the enterprise and Star Trek bridge
group literally lets you do that so it's
an oculus rift game you have to have for
oculus rift be able to play or be
playing online with your friends I was
playing in a room with three other
people
one person's capped in one person in
charge of shields and stuff one person
charged of life support and everyone's
got their own little jobs to do and the
captain tells you what to do so I was in
charge of shields and torpedoes and
you've got a little console in front of
you and you can see your hands but
obviously they're not your hands
reaching out and touching the console
and it really feels like you're actually
in control the enterprise
it was one of the best games I've ever
played but unfortunately is one of those
things where I'm probably never gonna be
able to recreate that experience again
because I need people I need for oculus
rifts for high-end pcs running that it's
just going to be quite hard to recreate
that but if I can somehow do that then I
really want to play it again because you
kind of feel like it would be more fun
if the mission was going badly our
mission went perfectly I kind of want to
see what it's like if I was in the
captain's chair I'm sure it probably
wouldn't go as well
we are Starfleet well that's it for this
week don't forget you can watch any of
our episodes on our YouTube playlist
just type in Sky News white stay up to
date with all the latest tech stories on
my news on mobile tablet catch up sky
kids and snapchat we'll see you again
next week buh-bye
you